- I have to ask if something
else is true, though.
You never travel without a clown nose?
What's happening there?
What's that mean?
- What's that about?
- What is that about?
- Well, I've been on the road for
about seven years now.
- Okay.
- And you just have these things
that you just kind of hold onto.
- Okay.
- One is this speaker.
- Okay. I love it.
I love your songs.
- And yeah, thank you.
- Yep. Yep.
- And one is
this thing here.
- Oh my God, it's got
a little leather pouch.
- It's got a little,
it's actually,
I'm not gonna tell you
what it's made out of.
'Cause you know, don't want no problems.
- You don't want people
hating on you, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But this
is it.
- Wait, what?
How long have you had that?
Oh, that string is old.
- Yeah.
- That string is about to break.
- This has been used.
- Yeah.
- This is the, this is the clown nose.
And
- Where did you get that?
- So you earned this clown nose
your final
year at the,
at that time
it was called the Yale School of Drama.
- Yeah.
- It is now called
the David something School of Drama.
- Yeah.
- Still my school,
but a different name.
- Yeah.
- But yeah at YSD
- Somebody else paid
more money or something?
(Kelly Clarkson laughing)
- Yeah.
Big dog.
Big dog came in, you know, took over.
- Like, nevermind.
I want my name on there.
- Yeah, like Jerry Jones.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Where else?
- Buying everything!
- And, and you get this,
you get this nose
in your acting training.
It's given to you
from a gentleman named Christopher Bayes.
Who was one of my dear teachers
and mentors and friends.
And
the nose is
the last
frontier of drama school.
And it gives you access
to the untamed
individual that you are.
So, you know,
I gotta untamed daughter, right?
- Yeah.
- Nine years old.
Her emotions are up down, left, right
- Eight year old daughter.
- So you already know.
- I am just like, what
will teenager be like?
- And it's fascinating.
- Jesus.
- Yeah.
- And we love it.
But this, you know,
helps a 33 year old man.
Gives us permission
to go back to that place
- Yeah.
- and operate.
Because the characters, you know,
I'm fortunate enough to play,
jump all over the place.
- Yeah.
- You know.
And there's so many things
that can socialize you
to not do certain things.
You know, and stop your expression.
And this little trickster here
is a magic door
into my little nine year old self.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just love that.
I was like, what is
this story going to be?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- Little romantic but
- And it's like earned as well.
- Yeah.
I mean, I mean, everybody gets one.
- But you gotta make
it through the program.
You gotta get to the program and make it.
You can't ring the bell.
- You just said.
Yeah, yeah.
You just said Yale.
So yeah, I was like,
- Yeah Yale.
- Not many people get there that I know.